>> ♪ ♪
>> IT'S TIME FOR "ONE MORE
THING."
I WILL GO IN HONOR OF MOTHER'S
DAY, A MOM'S EDITION.
LEAVE YOURSELF ENOUGH WIGGLE
ROOM WHEN YOU NEED TO, YOU CAN
CLIMB OUT OF THE TRUMP HABIT
HOLE.
YOU MUST MAINTAIN BALANCE TO
ACCESS THAT LADDER.
FOR ALL OF OUR SAKES.
NUMBER 2 RUDY GIULIANI IS A NUT
JOB.
NUMBER 3:
>> OH!
>> NUMBER 4.
>> VERY NICE.
>> HAPPY MOTHER'S DAY.
>> AND "WATTERS WORLD" SATURDAY
AT 8 CLOCK AND I AM ON THE
"STORY" WITH MARTHA MacCALLUM
LATER TONIGHT.
>> PICKING UP ON JESSE'S THEME.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU REMEMBER
THAT SUNDAY IS MOTHER'S DAY.
HAVE YOU BROKEN INTO THAT
LAST-MINUTE DIVE INTO WHAT TO
GET THE SPECIAL LADY.
40% OF MOMS SAY ALL THEY WANT IS
SOMETHING SENTIMENTAL THAT
EXPRESSES YOU LOVE THEM.
LET'S GIVE A GROUP HUG TO THE
MOTHERS ON OUR STAFF.
>> YES.
>> MEGAN WITH HER BABY.
>> AND ANOTHER WITH HER CHILD.
>> AND OUR PAL KENNEDY AND HER
CHILDREN.
>> OH!
>> AND MY PAL KIMBERLY WITH HER
SON.
>> TERRIFIC.
AND HERE'S MY WIFE WITH HER 3
BABIES.
>> VERY NICE.
>> HAPPY MOTHER'S DAY.
>> YOU DIDN'T HAVE A PICTURE OF
ME WITH MY FERRETS BUT THAT'S
OKAY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T THINK
FERRETS WILL BE CHILDREN.
YOU ARE NARROW-MINDED.
SATURDAY ON THE GREG GUTFELD
SHOW.
A GREAT ENSEMBLE.
A GREAT ACTOR.
10 O'CLOCK SATURDAY.
AND MY FRIEND THE GREATEST BOOK
EVER WRITTEN BESIDES THE BIBLE.
THE GUTFELD MONOLOGUES.
ALL OF THE MONOLOGUES I DO HERE
IN IN BOOK.
PRE-ORDER
PRE-ORDER AT
PRE-ORDER ATOM
PRE-ORDER ATO
PRE-ORDER AT
PRE-ORDER AT AM
PRE-ORDER AT AMAZ
PRE-ORDER AT AMAZON
PRE-ORDER AT AMAZON.C
PRE-ORDER AT AMAZON.COM
PRE-ORDER AT AMAZON.COM.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST BOOK I EDIT
MY OWN BOOK AND LEAVE THE NOTES
IN AND SAY WHERE I WENT WRONG.
NO ONE HAS EVER DONE THAT.
>> THAT'S WHY IT'S SO LONG.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> WELL, I HATE CATS BECAUSE
THEY ARE LITTLE DEVIL HAMSTERS.
A WOMAN IN TEXAS THOUGHT SHE
FOUND A COUPLE OF KITTENS.
TOOK THEM HOME, BUT THEY GOT
BIGGER.
EVERY TIME SHE FED THEM THEY
WOULD CLAW AND SCRATCH HER AND
HER RELATIVES TO THE POINT THEY
WERE SO AGGRESSIVE THEY WERE
STARTING TO DO HARM.
SHE CALLED ANIMAL CONTROL
SERVICES.
THEY WERE BABY BOBCATS!
THESE ARE WILD ANIMALS.
>> YOU CAN SEE THE DIFFERENCE.
>> HOUSE CATS WANT TO EAT YOU
BOUQUET THAT HE WENT.
YOU, BUT THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TINY MOUTHS.
THEY WOULD MAIM HER FACE.
>> MEOW.
NOW TEXAS IS INVESTIGATING HER
TO SEE IF SHE PENNED THEM IN.
>> IT'S A LOT OF THIS HAPPENING.
>> YES.
>> THE CUTE LITTLE WHITE FACE.
>> THAT DOESN'T JUST HAPPEN WITH
ANIMALS MY FRIEND.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I HAD A WILD WEEKEND.
>> INDEED.
>> I LEARNED A LOT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
KIMBERLY.
>> ANOTHER MONOLOGUE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IT'S A FABULOUS FRIDAY.
WE WANT TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS
TO RICK THE FABULOUS WEATHERMAN
HERE AT FOX NEWS CHANNEL AND
CAME OUT WITH A NEW COLOR FOR
THE WEATHERMAN UMBRELLA.
I WILL GIVE THIS ONE TO YOU FOR
MOTHER'S DAY.
THIS IS THE PINK COLOR.
THANKS TO SUSAN FOR A WONDERFUL
JOB AT THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
>> THERE SHE IS.
>> THANKS FOR YOUR EFFORTS AND
GOD BLESS.
>> VERY NICE.
>> I AM JEALOUS OF THEIR